when I eat a really big snack that's
going to keep me full for a long time
this is what I made step one we make a
dip and Tick Tock is obsessed with
because she's for good reason it's got
14 grams of protein per half cup and
it's packed with casein protein which is
a slow digesting protein so it keeps you
Fuller longer we're gonna puree that
until it's smooth all right taking a tip
out of my mom's cookbook we got some
french onion soup mix here and one of my
favorite burger toppings of all time we
got some caramelized onions
a little extra sweetness in there it's
optional but it definitely takes it up a
notch protein Rich dip done let's make a
snack plate all right gonna finish it
off with some everything but the bagel
seasoning a little pine nuts and all our
paper Dippers got some whole grain
crackers and lots of veg you make this
and you're not gonna be thinking about
food until hours later so if you need
more satiating snack or meal ideas I've
got a full ebook of my Hunger crush and
combos for free to download if you hit
up my link in bio